you're saying that billionaires should
not exist so are you basically saying
that once you get to 999 million dollars
but the government should confiscate all
the rest I'm saying that we should go
back to a very progressive tax policy
like what we had under Dwight D Isaac
which would mean that that over a
billion dollars basically it all goes to
the government all right you may
disagree with me all of it goes to the
government yeah I think people can make
it on 900 you know 99 million dollars
you're saying you know he doesn't say
though so your money you're at 999
million right but now you're invest now
you get the rest is gone but now you're
investing in that money every single
time it drips over they're just going to
keep taking your money
but here's the thing okay if the
government could show
that when the money is given to you you
pay off your debt you're in a better
financial position and you make better
Investments that grow the GDP at a
faster Pace than the private Market can
do well then you have an argument but
you have a horrible resume of this you
know give the money above 200 a billion
dollars to the US government here's what
he says he announces support for
President Joe Biden and called for a
return to a very progressive tax policy
that was like that was under the white
eyes and I introduced new legislation in
April called for the 99.9 percent act
which calls for wealthy heirs to pay
more on their inheritance by expanding
the estate tax to 45
on a state's worth at least three and a
half million dollars it would also
impose a 65 tax on billionaires tax on a
state's worth a billion 65
parents worked hard for this money and
now the government's going to say no no
we did more for you to make this money
than you did give that money to us Tom
what are your thoughts on this argument
with Bernie Sanders because it goes to
me similar to what New York and
California wants to do well I look at it
this way I don't see an argument what I
see I really I don't see an argument you
have to understand where Bernie's coming
from Bernie is not trying to argue about
changing percentages and things in the
structure of the current the current
country they want a restructuring of the
company into a a socialist
socialist construct supported by Marxist
themes that's what they want they want
to wholesale change the country so when
you look at it and you and you sit
inside of a a democratic capitalist you
know freedom and liberty construct and
these people say this to you you say you
people are insane well they are insane
in that argument they're not insane when
they look at their argument and their
argument is say look they're trying to
convert this to a socialist construct
they don't care about the debt they want
the debt to crash the system they want
the outcome of that there's no argument
here that I see what I see is them
slowly pulling the rug out from under
the the the construct of the countries
we know it to get to their socialist
Paradigm supported by Marxist themes
that's what I see that's the fundamental
transformation of America that when you
heard Barack Obama talking about in 2008
and people had a really hard time
visualizing what that was this is it and
I think you know these people want
mediocrity they want you know they want
that and they want people who've done
better than that that's correct
mediocrity breeds dependency on the
institutions they love by the way a lot
of these Democrats are very big Pharma
alleys allies it it just it also
encourages people who have been
successful to want to do what pick up
and leave there's so many successful
people now that don't even want to be in
the United States anymore they're like
where can I go because they see that
this is seeping through and seeping
through my two messages to Bernie one is
it's not up to you this is not your
money somebody else has earned this
money it's not up to you to decide if a
million is too much or 10 million is too
much or or a billion is too much it's
not your money hands off people's money
it's not up to you and secondly Pat you
made a great point about you know what
the government does completely and
efficiently with that money you can't
trust that your money's going to be used
well and a lot of times these wealthy
people will donate to charity will do so
much better with their money than
handing it over to government
bureaucracy that does what throws money
at education no results throws money at
the military no results throws money
where what has the government government
done well if you can delineate from me
what the government has done well with
your money then you have an argument
I'll wait there's no and by the way
here's the same guy that used to
criticize Millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires hey Bernie
you're a millionaire all right a
billionaires a billion
like jet said you're hitting that
billion and all that money you have no
idea where it's going and then you
nailed the jet they're going to send it
to Ukraine they're going to send it to
places where there's war and like
that it's just like you don't have the
money to even open your mouth it's it's
unbelievable by the way jet said
something very important you have no
right on what a person wants to do with
their money stop trying to make
decisions thinking it's your money and
it's your children those two things
leave the children alone and leave their
money alone both are theirs they've paid
a price for it not shoe but that's the
core argument the core argument is the
children are the children of the State
under the Socialist construct they are
there and you didn't earn that there was
a structure around you and they argue
energy infrastructure sewage all these
things electricity that was there and
your success was based on that so you
really don't deserve all this and it
goes back to Barack Obama you didn't
build that so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]